I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
我知道现在才年初，但我们已经在讨论暑假的家庭旅行了。你知道我们喜欢住Airbnb。我知道。嗯，我们喜欢有厨房，我喜欢早上能穿着睡袍走出来喝杯茶，正如你所说的，珍娜，我喜欢一段长长的跑道。是的。嗯，你知道，李现在在俄克拉荷马州工作，我们要去看他，他给我们找了一个非常好的Airbnb，让我们全家住在一起。这样我们就可以分散开来，每个人都能睡个好觉。然后你会感觉就像在家里一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah.
即使你在一个不同的城市。天哪，我可不想和我的全家人睡在同一个房间里。这就是为什么我再也受不了酒店了。是的，因为你们都挤在一起，共用一个浴室。是的，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，一个真正的冰箱。你知道的，我喜欢吃零食。我确实知道这一点。是的，我不想叫客房服务。我想要它们就在那儿。没错。是的。
Everyone we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess, for your next adventure for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. pepper sauce poured with ease. And if smoky strips of bacon make burgers better, you'll love our cheesy jalapeno and bacon quarter pounder. Get this beefy, bold, bacony, melty mouthful. Only at McDonald's for a limited time. Welcome to the second drink of The Carpet. You know, I've got some deleted scenes I want to share with you guys, but we also need to discuss some of the mail
大家，我想我们是爱住Airbnb的女士，对于你的下一次冒险，你的下一次假期，也许可以考虑Airbnb。胡椒酱轻松倒出。如果烟熏培根条能让汉堡更美味，你一定会喜欢我们的芝士墨西哥辣椒培根四分之一磅汉堡。来尝尝这口肉香四溢、大胆、培根味十足、芝士融化的美味吧。仅在麦当劳限时供应。欢迎来到《地毯》的第二杯饮料。你知道，我有一些删减片段想和你们分享，但我们也需要讨论一下我们收到的一些邮件，
we got on this one, lady. We got so much mail. So much. It had to do with our off-topic conversation about Game of Thrones. Because Angela, you mentioned in this breakdown that you thought Dwight would love Game of Thrones. And well, tons of you wrote in to tell us that Dwight does like Game of Thrones and even teaches Aaron Dothraki later in Andy's ancestry. I mean, of course he does, as when we got to Andy's ancestry, we discovered. My bad. Thank you for writing in.
女士，我们收到了很多邮件。非常多。这与我们关于《权力的游戏》的离题谈话有关。因为安吉拉，你在这次解析中提到你认为德怀特会喜欢《权力的游戏》。嗯，你们中有很多人写信告诉我们，德怀特确实喜欢《权力的游戏》，甚至在安迪的祖先那一集中教艾琳多斯拉克语。我的意思是，他当然喜欢，当我们讲到安迪的祖先时，我们发现了。我的错。谢谢你们的来信。
It's one of those things people ask me all the time, what's it like to watch it all these years later? There's things that I forgot. Same. Right? Especially scenes I wasn't in. Yes. Well, thank you very much, Hailey, Bobby G., Adina, Kaitlyn, Jordan D., Ben W., Joe W.,
这是人们一直问我的事情之一，多年后再看这部剧是什么感觉？有些事情我忘记了。我也是。对吧？尤其是那些我没参与的场景。是的。嗯，非常感谢海莉、鲍比·G、阿迪娜、凯特琳、乔丹·D、本·W、乔·W，
and many more. Many more. And Jenna, you shared that you had tried to watch two and a half episodes of Game of Thrones of season one. You did it for me, lady. But it did not go great. You did not like the opening credits. You did not like all the new, like, topography and the names of stuff you might have to learn.
还有更多的人。还有很多。珍娜，你分享说你试着看了《权力的游戏》第一季的两集半。你是为了我才看的，女士。但过程并不顺利。你不喜欢片头字幕。你不喜欢所有那些新的，比如，地形和那些你可能需要学习的东西的名字。
You also did not like the queen or her brother, but you did like the White Walkers. I don't even remember who they are. The White Walkers? What? You don't remember the White Walkers? What are they? Are they spirits? Are they spirits? Are they people?
你也不喜欢女王或她的兄弟，但你喜欢异鬼。我甚至不记得他们是谁了。异鬼？什么？你不记得异鬼了？他们是什么？他们是灵魂吗？他们是灵魂吗？他们是人吗？
How can you forget? Is that the snow guy? Is the snow guy a White Walker? Yes. Oh, yeah. And they protect that weird, very, very cold light. They don't protect it so much as they just want to take over. There's a wall.
你怎么能忘记呢？那是雪人吗？雪人是异鬼吗？是的。哦，是的。他们保护着那种奇怪的、非常非常冷的光。与其说他们保护它，不如说他们只是想接管一切。有一堵墙。
Oh, my lord. Okay. Listen. Okay. We can't go down this road again. Okay. But you did say, and I quote, do we need to start a second podcast where I rewatch Game of Thrones and we discuss it. You called it Office Ladies Do Game of Thrones. We got a lot of mail about that moment. Jennifer A. said, I would love to hear an Office Ladies Watch Game of Thrones podcast.
天哪。好吧。听着。好吧。我们不能再走这条路了。好吧。但你确实说过，我引用一下，我们需要开启第二个播客，让我重看《权力的游戏》并讨论它吗？你把它叫做“办公室女士看权力的游戏”。我们收到了很多关于那一刻的邮件。詹妮弗·A说，我很想听《办公室女士看权力的游戏》这个播客。
Please do this. Wally H. said, I was yelling at this podcast. You have to do a Game of Thrones podcast. I need that in my life. Several other people wrote in saying they would love it. One fellow said, please don't do that. Please stop talking about Game of Thrones. But I mean, I would love it. I would do it, but only if I just watch it and then discuss my reaction. I don't wanna have to research it. I don't wanna tell you where things were filmed. You don't wanna be like, okay, I've got a location for you. Exactly.
请一定要做这个。沃利·H说，我对着这个播客大喊。你们必须做一个《权力的游戏》播客。我的生活中需要这个。其他几个人写信说他们会很喜欢。有一个人说，请不要那样做。请停止谈论《权力的游戏》。但我的意思是，我会很喜欢。我会做的，但前提是我只是看它，然后讨论我的反应。我不想去研究它。我不想告诉你东西是在哪里拍摄的。你不想表现得像，好吧，我为你找到了一个拍摄地点。完全正确。
Because it's already gonna be so much for me. Although I would a little bit love to hear where they got those dragon eggs and stuff, like the props person having to make those dragon eggs and stuff, like the props person having to make the dragon eggs that the lady is protecting. So you remembered the dragon eggs, but you didn't remember what a white walker was? Well the eggs were very memorable. I mean there's some eggs that were just waiting for them to hatch for so long.
因为这对我来说已经够多了。虽然我确实有点想听听他们是从哪里弄到那些龙蛋之类的东西，比如道具师不得不制作那些龙蛋之类的东西，比如道具师不得不制作那位女士正在保护的龙蛋。所以你记得龙蛋，但你不记得什么是异鬼？嗯，那些蛋非常令人难忘。我的意思是，有些蛋等待孵化太久了。
Okay, I say this, if we do this, you can pick and choose what you wanna research. You wanna find out who made the egg, where the eggs were, maybe I wanna find out, you know, where that big tree is they all like to hang out by. You don't know what I'm talking about. I have no idea what you're talking about. Okay, lastly, we have some deleted scenes to kick off this episode.
好吧，我说这个，如果我们这样做，你可以挑选你想研究的内容。你想找出是谁制作了蛋，蛋在哪里，也许我想找出，你知道，他们都喜欢待着的那棵大树在哪里。你不知道我在说什么。我完全不知道你在说什么。好吧，最后，我们有一些删减片段来开启这一集。
We discussed some of them in our breakdown, but we didn't play any of them. And I want to share this Kevin talking head. It's about who he thinks might have pooped on the carpet. And I want you to listen really carefully to Kevin's voice, and then we need to discuss. Okay. There's so many people with motives, even me.
我们在解析中讨论了其中一些，但我们没有播放任何片段。我想分享这个凯文的访谈片段。这是关于他认为是谁在地毯上拉了屎。我希望你非常仔细地听凯文的声音，然后我们需要讨论一下。好吧。有很多人有动机，甚至包括我。
Almost everyone is a suspect. Whoever did this is a genius. All right. There's no Kevin voice there. Yeah, there's Kevin voice. No, there's not. There's a little bit of Stacey in there. There's a little bit of like, I don't know. No, no, no. This is when Brian is finding Kevin's voice. I am telling you, if you listen to the beginning, it's Brian, and then he slowly pivots into Kevin. So you think this is kind of his transition period where he was finding it?
几乎每个人都是嫌疑人。做这件事的人是个天才。好吧。那里没有凯文的声音。是的，有凯文的声音。不，没有。里面有一点点斯泰西的声音。有一点点，我不知道。不，不，不。这是布莱恩在寻找凯文声音的时候。我告诉你，如果你听开头，那是布莱恩，然后他慢慢转变为凯文。所以你认为这是他寻找声音的过渡期吗？
Yes. There's more deleted scenes and all of them I hear Brian. Hmm. Good catch, lady. Anyone else? Anyone else hear Brian? I like it. Don't shake me off, Sam. No, I don't. Oh, stop it. Brian, I like it. Don't shake me off, Sam.
是的。还有更多的删减片段，所有片段里我都听到了布莱恩的声音。嗯。抓得好，女士。还有其他人吗？还有其他人听到布莱恩的声音吗？我喜欢。别甩掉我，萨姆。不，我没有。哦，别这样。布莱恩，我喜欢。别甩掉我，萨姆。
No, I don't. Oh, stop it. Well, Angela, I also have a deleted scene for us to listen to. You mentioned it when we broke down this episode. You said that there was a lot more Dwight and Angela in the deleted scenes. And I thought that this moment in the kitchen was so sweet.
不，我没有。哦，别这样。好吧，安吉拉，我也有一个删减片段让我们听听。你在解析这一集时提到了它。你说删减片段里有更多的德怀特和安吉拉。我觉得厨房里的这一刻太甜了。
So this is when Michael has been giving Dwight a hard time about his sales record, and then Angela walks into the kitchen. They have a little moment. I want us to hear it. Okay, look, I know what you're going to say, that I'm not standing up for myself, but you know what? It's complicated.
所以这是迈克尔一直因为销售记录而为难德怀特的时候，然后安吉拉走进厨房。他们有了一个小小的互动。我希望我们听听。好吧，听着，我知道你要说什么，说我没有为自己挺身而出，但你知道吗？这很复杂。
I really don't appreciate all the badgering. You could outsell Michael any day. And then Dwight has this look on his face. He's so happy. Well, I always love then Dwight has this look on his face. He's so happy. Well, I always love it when Angela has his back, you know? Mm-hmm. Yeah.
我真的不欣赏所有的纠缠。你随时都可以比迈克尔卖得更多。然后德怀特脸上露出了那种表情。他太开心了。嗯，我总是喜欢安吉拉支持他的时候，你知道吗？嗯哼。是的。
Well, there you have it. This is a super fun episode. And now here's our breakdown of the carpet. Hey, gang, you know we like to keep our podcast PG. Well, I blew it on this one, guys. I'm sorry. So we wanted to warn you before you listen in case you're listening with your kids. Around the 20 minute mark, Angela goes off the rails.
好了，就是这样。这是一个超级有趣的剧集。现在是我们的地毯解析。嘿，伙计们，你知道我们喜欢保持我们的播客PG级。嗯，我在这集搞砸了，伙计们。我很抱歉。所以我们想在你们收听之前提醒你们，以防你们和孩子们一起听。在20分钟左右，安吉拉失控了。
Well, hey, wait a second. I just tell a story about an episode of Fear Factor. It's got some adult- There's no other way to tell it. There's some adult subject matter. You told it how you needed to. And you might want to put earmuffs on the kids at the 20 minute mark. Turn it down, skip five minutes ahead, whatever you need to do. And for the rest, you know, put earmuffs on the kids at the 20 minute mark. Turn it down, skip five minutes ahead,
好吧，嘿，等一下。我只是讲了一个关于《恐惧因素》节目的故事。它有一些成人的——没有其他方式来讲述它。它有一些成人的主题内容。你按照你需要的方式讲述了它。你们可能想在20分钟的时候给孩子们戴上耳罩。调低音量，跳过五分钟，无论你们需要做什么。对于其他人，你知道，在20分钟的时候给孩子们戴上耳罩。调低音量，跳过五分钟，
whatever you need to do, and for the rest of you, enjoy. And sorry. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you.
无论你们需要做什么，对于你们其他人，享受吧。抱歉。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》重看播客。
Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi, Ange. Hey, Jenna. Why are you looking at me like that? Because I have some sciatica pain in my hip.
每周，我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。嗨，安吉。嘿，珍娜。你为什么那样看着我？因为我的臀部有坐骨神经痛。
Oh Lord, is this how we're starting today? Yeah. All right, what else you got? Well, I was trying to stretch it and you told me I had to sit down. You guys, she was kicking her leg in the air. It was comfortable. But you- It felt good.
天哪，我们今天就是这样开始的吗？是的。好吧，你还有什么？嗯，我试着伸展它，你告诉我我必须坐下。伙计们，她当时在空中踢腿。这很舒服。但你——这感觉很好。
You think you can do that for 45 minutes? I think I can, yeah. Okay, go, you go girl. I thought I could kick my leg and do this podcast at the same time, but Angela told me to sit down. I did because I didn't say it like that. I was like, A, you're going to hurt yourself.
你觉得你能那样做45分钟吗？我想我可以，是的。好吧，去吧，加油。我以为我可以一边踢腿一边做这个播客，但安吉拉叫我坐下。我确实说了，因为我不是那样说的。我是说，A，你会伤到自己的。
B, I don't think I can concentrate. Why did you kick your foot up like that? All right. Well, I might need to do it midway, but let's get started. Okay, Jenna. When you do it midway, I'm going to film you and I'm going to put it on OfficeLadies.com. All right. Today we are talking about the carpet. When you do it midway, I'm gonna film you and I'm gonna put it on officeladies.com. Alright. Today we are talking about The Carpet.
B，我不认为我能集中注意力。你为什么要那样踢脚？好吧。嗯，我可能需要在中途做一下，但让我们开始吧。好吧，珍娜。当你中途做的时候，我会拍下你，我会把它放在OfficeLadies.com上。好吧。今天我们讨论的是地毯。当你中途做的时候，我会拍下你，我会把它放在officeladies.com上。好吧。今天我们讨论的是《地毯》。
Ooh. It is season two, episode 14, written by Paul Lieberstein, aka Toby, and directed by Victor Nellie Jr. Yeah. I'm gonna give you a summary. Do it. In this episode, someone leaves a gift on Michael's carpet. You could call it that.
噢。这是第二季第14集，由保罗·利伯斯坦（又名托比）编剧，维克多·内利二世执导。是的。我要给你一个总结。做吧。在这一集中，有人在迈克尔的地毯上留下了一份礼物。你可以这样称呼它。
In his office. It is soft. It is smelly. You're going to describe it? It is brown. Gross. But the question is, who done it? Michael is determined to find out.
在他的办公室里。它很软。它很臭。你要描述它吗？它是棕色的。恶心。但问题是，是谁干的？迈克尔决心查个水落石出。
Everyone's a suspect. He suspects everyone in the office. To keep a close eye on the office, he takes over Jim's desk, which forces Jim to go work at an empty desk right next to Kelly. And Jim quickly learns why Kelly works in the back by herself. But the biggest surprise of this episode might be that you finally see Pam and Roy getting along. They've come back from a vacation and they're
每个人都是嫌疑人。他怀疑办公室里的每一个人。为了密切监视办公室，他接管了吉姆的办公桌，这迫使吉姆去凯莉旁边的一张空桌子工作。吉姆很快就明白了为什么凯莉一个人在后面工作。但这一集最大的惊喜可能是你终于看到帕姆和罗伊和睦相处了。他们刚度假回来，他们
all giggly. They're giggly. They've been in the Poconos. Yeah. Which I Googled. It's only about 51 minutes from Scranton. And is it snowy? It's snowy because this was January and here are the best activities because I went down the rabbit hole of the Poconos. Now I want to go to the Poconos. It's beautiful. In the winter, here are the best activities to do in the Poconos, ready? One hour away from Scranton, snow tubing, skiing, snowboarding, a casino, snowmobile, ice skating, snow shoeing, there's a brewery and a spa.
都在傻笑。他们很傻。他们去了波科诺山。是的，我谷歌了一下。离斯克兰顿只有51分钟的路程。那里下雪吗？那里下雪，因为这是在一月，这里是最好的活动，因为我钻进了波科诺山的兔子洞。现在我想去波科诺山。那里很美。在冬天，这里是波科诺山最好的活动，准备好了吗？离斯克兰顿一小时路程，雪上漂流、滑雪、单板滑雪、赌场、雪地摩托、滑冰、雪鞋行走，还有一个啤酒厂和一个水疗中心。
Oh, I bet Roy went to the brewery. Yeah. I mean. I mean, yeah. That's for sure. They pretty much did that in the casino. Jim asked Pam if she did a lot of skiing and she says not really. Yes, or a little a little a little. All right. Are you ready for some fast facts? I am. And then at some point, Jenna, you'll have to let me know with your sciatica and all of that business. Yeah, I do have a gift for you. You do? Yes. And I want to share it with you right here with all of our office ladies listeners
哦，我敢打赌罗伊去了啤酒厂。是的。我的意思是。我的意思是，是的。那是一定的。他们在赌场里几乎就是那样做的。吉姆问帕姆是否经常滑雪，她说不太经常。是的，或者一点点，一点点，一点点。好吧。你准备好听一些快速事实了吗？我准备好了。然后到某个时候，珍娜，你得让我知道你的坐骨神经痛和所有那些事情。是的，我确实有一份礼物给你。你有吗？是的。我想在这里和我们所有的《办公室女士》听众分享它，
because y'all been listening. Oh my gosh, who am I? I should tell you guys, my sister Janet from Texas has been here for a week. And so I just said, y'all been listening. Yeah, when you two get together, you get all Southern. I get very Southern. So anyway, you guys will get it.
因为你们一直在听。天哪，我是谁？我应该告诉你们，我来自德克萨斯的妹妹珍妮特已经在这里待了一周了。所以我只是说，你们一直在听。是的，当你们两个聚在一起时，你们就变得很南方了。我变得非常南方。所以无论如何，你们会明白的。
You'll be in on the joke. And that's why I want to give it to you during a podcast. Do you want to give it to me right now before we start with fast facts? I guess we should after I've said all that. That's a big buildup. You're probably really curious. Oh, it's wrapped in bubble wrap, just like Michael's foot from the injury. Look at you with your little office callback. That's right. You guys that have been listening know that Jenna hasn't really seen Star Wars and it's okay. I've come to terms with this you guys. I don't like scary movies. This is an impasse in our friendship. What are we going to do? We don't know. So anyway, but you did say you love
你们会明白这个笑话的。这就是为什么我想在播客期间把它给你。你想在开始快速事实之前现在就给我吗？我想在我们说了这么多之后我们应该这样做。这是一个很大的铺垫。你可能真的很好奇。哦，它用气泡膜包着，就像迈克尔受伤的脚一样。看看你，带着你的小《办公室》回扣。没错。你们这些一直在听的人知道珍娜并没有真正看过《星球大战》，没关系。我已经接受了这一点，伙计们。我不喜欢恐怖电影。这是我们友谊中的僵局。我们该怎么办？我们不知道。所以无论如何，但你确实说过你喜欢
Star Wars sort of memorabilia and things. You were Princess Leia for Halloween as a kid. Yeah. Right? All right. So remember my little baby Yoda? No. My crocheted baby Yoda. Stop it. Stop it. Okay. So I have to give a huge shout out to Shay.
《星球大战》之类的纪念品和东西。你小时候万圣节扮过莱娅公主。是的。对吧？好吧。所以记得我的小尤达宝宝吗？不。我钩针编织的尤达宝宝。别这样。别这样。好吧。所以我必须给谢伊一个巨大的呼喊。
He crocheted this. He is one of my Insta-Pal friends. His name on Instagram is, oh Shay, what is it? It's Forron Fleek. Am I saying that right? I hope so. But he heard how much you loved mine and Jenna. Oh.
他钩针编织了这个。他是我的Instagram好友之一。他在Instagram上的名字是，哦谢伊，是什么？是Forron Fleek。我读对了吗？我希望如此。但他听说你有多喜欢我和珍娜的那个。哦。
He made you one. Look at him, baby Yoda. Oh my gosh. In his little crib and it's crocheted by hand. And look, it's a Christmas ornament. It's a Christmas ornament. Well, you know, two of my favorite things are Christmas decor.
他为你做了一个。看看他，尤达宝宝。天哪。在他小小的摇篮里，这是手工钩针编织的。看，这是一个圣诞装饰品。这是一个圣诞装饰品。嗯，你知道，我最喜欢的两件事是圣诞装饰。
And handmade Christmas stuff. You love that. And also baby things. I know. Like things are Christmas decor. And handmade Christmas stuff. You love that. And also baby things, like things made into babies. I know. Right? Baby elephant. I was just watching this movie Journey 2 with my son and they have little bitty tiny elephants on the island. The elephants are shrunk down and they're little and they're so cute when they're tiny. Well, now you have a tiny baby Yoda crochet. And that's from Shay, Jenna. Oh, Shay, thank you so much. Angela, thank you so much.
和手工圣诞物品。你喜欢那个。还有婴儿用品。我知道。比如圣诞装饰品。和手工圣诞物品。你喜欢那个。还有婴儿用品，比如做成婴儿的东西。我知道。对吧？小象。我刚才和儿子在看《地心历险记2》，岛上有小小的象。象被缩小了，它们很小，当它们很小时非常可爱。好吧，现在你有一个小小的尤达宝宝钩针编织品。那是谢伊给的，珍娜。哦，谢伊，非常感谢。安吉拉，非常感谢。
Well, Angela, I had to have one. I have a surprise for you, but I'm going to save it. Is it a scary movie you're going to make me see? I got you a severed head from a most famous, famous scary movie. I got you Freddie's glove. No, I didn't. This is not a tangible item that I'm gonna hand you,
好吧，安吉拉，我必须有一个。我有一个惊喜给你，但我打算留着它。是你打算让我看的恐怖电影吗？我给你弄了一个最著名的恐怖电影里的断头。我给你弄了弗雷迪的手套。不，我没有。这不是一个我可以递给你的有形物品，
but it is a thing I'm gonna tell you. Okay, I can't wait. Let's start with fast fact number one. I declare with full authority. Bankruptcy, no. We have reached full Mindy. The carpet is when we reach full Mindy. This is full Mindy you guys, you're gonna hear it.
但这是一件我要告诉你的事情。好吧，我等不及了。让我们从快速事实第一条开始。我以全部权威宣布。破产，不。我们已经达到了完全的明迪。地毯这一集是我们达到完全明迪的时候。这是完全的明迪，伙计们，你们会听到的。
You know it, it's happening. I asked Sam to make a compilation of all of the things that the character of Kelly says to Jim back in the annex to prove that we have hit full Mindy. So first of all, the hair is transformed. The hair is pretty much down, just a tiny clip, but it's fashionable. The outfit, super pink, fluffy.
你知道的，它正在发生。我让萨姆做了一个凯莉对吉姆说的所有话的合集，在附楼里，以证明我们已经达到了完全的明迪。首先，发型变了。头发基本上是放下来的，只有一个小发夹，但很时尚。服装，超级粉色，毛茸茸的。
Skirt. All of it. Pink lipstick. She sits on her desk. She puts her feet up. She's like, I mean, come on. She also talks about Beyonce. This is a big thing.
裙子。所有的一切。粉色口红。她坐在桌子上。她把脚翘起来。她就像，我的意思是，得了吧。她还谈论碧昂丝。这是一件大事。
She talks about the color pink, she crushes on Ryan, and at the end, she breaks. Here it is in its glory, the full Mindy. Do it. I'm serious, my closet doors will not shut. Beyonce, pink the color, pink the person, hot dogs, basically anything that is awesome. Oh my God, he is so cute. Would you talk to him for me and see if he likes me?
她谈论粉色，她迷恋瑞安，最后，她崩溃了。这就是它的荣耀，完全的明迪。做吧。我是认真的，我的衣柜门关不上。碧昂丝，粉色这个颜色，粉色这个人，热狗，基本上任何很棒的东西。天哪，他太可爱了。你能帮我跟他谈谈，看看他是否喜欢我吗？
Oh, please, Jim, please, please, Jim, please, please, please, he's so cute. I like him so much and I would do it, but I'm too shy. Please, Jim, please, please, please, please, Jim, please, please, please. please, Jim, please, please, please. There you go. Oh man, and poor Jim this episode. We'll get to that.
哦，拜托，吉姆，拜托，拜托，吉姆，拜托，拜托，拜托，他太可爱了。我非常喜欢他，我会去做的，但我太害羞了。拜托，吉姆，拜托，拜托，拜托，拜托，吉姆，拜托，拜托，拜托。拜托，吉姆，拜托，拜托，拜托。给你。哦天哪，可怜的吉姆这一集。我们会讲到的。
But come on, Beyoncé, there's a lot of Mindy here. Yes, I think this is it. Now we're gonna track and see if she stays full Mindy. Don't worry, we're not done tracking this in case you were worried. Oh yeah, I mean, if you know, next episode has a bun, we're going to let you know. I'm pretty sure in Casino Night she gets extensions. Like suddenly that we never speak of or her character never speaks of, but she's got this
但得了吧，碧昂丝，这里有很多明迪。是的，我想就是这样。现在我们要追踪看看她是否保持完全的明迪。别担心，我们还没追踪完，以防你担心。哦是的，我的意思是，如果你知道，下一集有一个发髻，我们会让你知道的。我很确定在赌场之夜她接了接发。就像突然我们从未谈论过，或者她的角色从未谈论过，但她有这个
gorgeous long hair in Casino Night. So we'll track that as well. All right, fast fact number two. We have a big guest star. Ken Howard shows up as Ed Truck. Now, this is the only episode where we see this character, but we refer to him a lot. He was the boss of the office before Michael, and Michael worked under him when he was a salesman. Ken Howard is a famous character actor in Hollywood. First of all, he's six feet, six inches tall. Is that insane? He's so tall.
华丽的长发在赌场之夜。所以我们也会追踪那个。好吧，快速事实第二条。我们有一个大客串明星。肯·霍华德作为埃德·卡车出现。现在，这是我们看到这个角色的唯一一集，但我们经常提到他。他是迈克尔之前的办公室老板，迈克尔在他还是推销员时就在他手下工作。肯·霍华德是好莱坞著名的性格演员。首先，他身高六英尺六英寸。这不疯狂吗？他太高了。
You notice in the scene that he does with Steve that he's like kind of towering over Steve. He's a very large person. So Ken played basketball in school and he was offered a number of scholarships, but he turned them all down in favor of pursuing an acting career. And he started his career in the theater, Angela, a theater actor. What? Would you? I studied theater classes too, Jenna. You're like, Angela, it's this thing called theater. Theater actor. I mean, you know, I'm kind of a fancy theater person. Well, you know, I didn't meet Ken or share a scene with him, but our theater bond was
你注意到他和史蒂夫演的那场戏里，他有点像在史蒂夫上方耸立。他是一个非常大的人。所以肯在学校打篮球，他被提供了许多奖学金，但他拒绝了所有奖学金，转而追求演艺事业。他开始了他的戏剧生涯，安吉拉，一个戏剧演员。什么？你会吗？我也学习了戏剧课程，珍娜。你就像，安吉拉，这叫戏剧。戏剧演员。我的意思是，你知道，我算是一个时髦的戏剧人。好吧，你知道，我没有见过肯或和他分享一场戏，但我们的戏剧纽带是
felt. Did you study like dialects in your acting theater school? I see what you're doing there. Oh, do you? That was a dig. You know what? I see what you're doing. You're digging. All right, well, he won a Tony award. He appeared in over a hundred movies and television series
感受到的。你在你的表演戏剧学校学习过方言吗？我明白你在做什么。哦，是吗？那是一个挖苦。你知道吗？我明白你在做什么。你在挖苦。好吧，好吧，他赢得了托尼奖。他出现在一百多部电影和电视剧中
during his 47 year career. Unfortunately, Ken passed away in 2016, but he left behind this huge legacy. You know, he was even the president of the Screen Actors Guild Union for four years. So he is, guys, just an icon of the entertainment industry, and we were so lucky to have him for just this one scene. Oh, it was huge. We were thrilled, thrilled. So Angela, Fast Fact number three is my surprise to you. Oh, okay. Are you ready for it? I don't know.
在他47年的职业生涯中。不幸的是，肯在2016年去世了，但他留下了巨大的遗产。你知道，他甚至担任了四年演员工会的主席。所以他，伙计们，只是娱乐业的一个偶像，我们非常幸运能让他只演这一场戏。哦，这太大了。我们很激动，很激动。所以安吉拉，快速事实第三条是给你的惊喜。哦，好吧。你准备好了吗？我不知道。
I watched Game of Thrones. What? What? That's right. What episode? The first two and a half episodes. Did you really? Yeah.
我看了《权力的游戏》。什么？什么？没错。哪一集？前两集半。你真的看了吗？是的。
I couldn't turn it off. Do you like it? I have a lot of thoughts. Oh, no. Do you want my thoughts? Yes. Okay. So, first of all, episode one of Game of Thrones.
我无法关掉它。你喜欢它吗？我有很多想法。哦，不。你想要我的想法吗？是的。好吧。所以，首先，《权力的游戏》第一集。
Okay. Very horror movie, Angela. The White Walkers and the dismembered bodies. Oh, oh. Love that. I know. I was like, why didn't she tell me about this part? I'm in.
好吧。非常恐怖电影，安吉拉。异鬼和肢解的尸体。哦，哦。喜欢那个。我知道。我当时想，为什么她没告诉我这一部分？我加入了。
I thought you knew about the White Walkers. Jenna, we called my cat Otter the White Walker. I didn't know what that meant. I don't know what that means. It's because he was so old. He was like 22 years old and he barely had any fur left. And he'd be like, meh. And we called him the White Walker.
我以为你知道异鬼。珍娜，我们叫我的猫水獭为异鬼。我不知道那是什么意思。我不知道那是什么意思。那是因为他太老了。他大概22岁了，几乎没有毛了。他会像，咩。我们就叫他异鬼。
Well, I liked the opening. Then we cut to the credit sequence, which is going over this map of lands and names of lands. And I was just like, this is the part I don't want to learn. OK, that part is long. And just skip past it. And also as seasons change and the topography changes, those images change.
嗯，我喜欢开头。然后我们切到字幕序列，它正在浏览这张土地地图和土地名称。我当时就想，这是我不想学习的部分。OK，那部分很长。直接跳过它。而且随着季节变化和地形变化，那些图像也会变化。
But anyway, just skip over it. Then I want to say, there's a lot of brother sister love. Listen, in the beginning. Just a lot. In the beginning. And then I think that kind of tapers off a little bit. Okay. Jenna, listen, there's some messed up stuff. Okay. Well, I'm liking the, is it the Stark family?
但无论如何，直接跳过它。然后我想说，有很多兄妹之爱。听着，在开始的时候。只是很多。在开始的时候。然后我想那在某种程度上减少了一点。好吧。珍娜，听着，有一些混乱的事情。好吧。嗯，我喜欢，是史塔克家族吗？
Yes. Lord Stark. Yes. And his family. I'm digging on them. Oh, okay. I'm hating the queen and her brother. Oh, yeah, I know. Yes. Lord Stark. Yes. And his family. I'm digging on them. Oh, okay. I'm hating the Queen and her brother. Oh yeah. I know. Ooh. The Lannisters. Ooh, the Lannisters. Is that their name? Okay. But here's my big observation. Okay. And I want you to help me out here. This is fantasy, right? This is not based on anything. No, Game of Thrones
是的。史塔克大人。是的。还有他的家人。我喜欢他们。哦，好吧。我讨厌女王和她的兄弟。哦，是的，我知道。是的。史塔克大人。是的。还有他的家人。我喜欢他们。哦，好吧。我讨厌女王和她的兄弟。哦，是的。我知道。噢。兰尼斯特家族。噢，兰尼斯特家族。那是他们的名字吗？好吧。但这是我的大观察。好吧。我希望你在这里帮我一下。这是奇幻，对吧？这不是基于任何东西。不，《权力的游戏》
is just fantasy. Yeah. Okay. Here's my beef. Okay, you're only two episodes in. Go on. Two and a half. Here's my beef. That's why I want you to speak to this for me. Okay. Why can't the women do more than so and marry? Oh, they do.
只是奇幻。是的。好吧。这是我的不满。好吧，你才看了两集。继续。两集半。这是我的不满。这就是为什么我想让你为我谈谈这个。好吧。为什么女性除了缝纫和结婚什么都做不了？哦，她们会的。
They're going to do a lot more. Okay. I'm just saying that like you take the Wonder Woman thing, right? And it's fantasy. And so it's about like a badass island of women warriors because we can make up anything we want. It's not based in any real time period. So why does fantasy as a genre in general
她们会做更多的事情。好吧。我只是说就像你拿神奇女侠那件事来说，对吧？这是奇幻。所以它是关于一个坏蛋女性战士岛，因为我们可以编造任何我们想要的。它不是基于任何真实的历史时期。所以为什么奇幻作为一个类型通常
seem to put men and women in such traditional roles? Basically, especially for Game of Thrones, I mean, you guys out there that have watched it now, this is kind of a little bit of a subtle hint, but she's not going to get it. So you know, just ignore, ignore. The women pretty much end up burning it all to the ground. They are literally like, I am woman! They serve it up, lady.
似乎把男人和女人放在如此传统的角色中？基本上，特别是对于《权力的游戏》，我的意思是，你们这些现在看过的人，这算是一个小小的暗示，但她不会明白的。所以你知道，忽略，忽略。女性基本上最终把一切都烧毁了。她们简直就像，我是女人！她们把它端上来，女士。
Don't you worry. All right. They're going to dish it out. I really hope that that girl, the girl who loves the sword play, that's a- Aria? Oh yeah, trust me. Okay, hold on. Aria's gonna do, Aria's gonna be okay.
别担心。好吧。她们会把它分发出去。我真的希望那个女孩，那个喜欢剑术的女孩，那是——艾莉亚？哦是的，相信我。好吧，等一下。艾莉亚会做的，艾莉亚会没事的。
Aria has a list, I'm not even gonna get into it. Ooh, wait, whoa, wait, wait, she has a list? You don't wanna be on her list. You know, you know I love a list. Oh, honey, you don't wanna be on this list. Ooh, I can't wait for Aria's list. Oh, it's good. Okay.
艾莉亚有一个名单，我甚至不想深入讨论它。噢，等等，哇，等等，等等，她有一个名单？你不想出现在她的名单上。你知道，你知道我喜欢名单。哦，亲爱的，你不想出现在这个名单上。噢，我等不及艾莉亚的名单了。哦，它很好。好吧。
I wanna say one last thing, and we can cut this out if this goes on too long. I want to just say one last thing. Winter is coming. We get it. It's coming, guys. I mean, how many times per episode do they need to say winter is coming?
我想说最后一件事，如果这持续太久我们可以剪掉它。我只想说最后一件事。凛冬将至。我们明白了。它要来了，伙计们。我的意思是，每集他们需要说多少次凛冬将至？
And also, this winter, it's like, I feel like they have the wrong name for it. It doesn't sound like a winter is coming. It sounds like an avalanche is coming to bury you for seven years in cold. It's an avalanche of dead walking people, okay? I mean, they're coming. That's what's coming?
而且，这个冬天，就像，我觉得他们给它起错了名字。听起来不像凛冬将至。听起来像雪崩要来把你埋在寒冷中七年。这是一场死人行走的雪崩，好吗？我的意思是，他们来了。这就是要来的东西？
The white walkers are coming. So the white walkers come with winter, but the white walkers aren't affected by winter? Jenna, I'm not gonna get into it. I'm not gonna get into it. I'm not gonna get into it. I mean, that's not what I'm saying. It's like so many things. All I'm saying is winter is coming
异鬼来了。所以异鬼随冬天而来，但异鬼不受冬天影响？珍娜，我不会深入讨论它。我不会深入讨论它。我不会深入讨论它。我的意思是，我不是那个意思。就像很多事情。我只想说凛冬将至
is a layered metaphor, okay? It's not just the cold. Oh, okay. Okay. All right, well, good. And the Dothraki's, am I saying it right? The Dothraki's, yeah. And Carl Drago?
是一个分层的隐喻，好吗？不仅仅是寒冷。哦，好吧。好吧。好吧，嗯，很好。还有多斯拉克人，我读对了吗？多斯拉克人，是的。还有卡尔·卓戈？
Yeah. Is this named Carl? No, it's Cal. Oh, Cal. I love that you thought that the guy that speaks no English and is shirtless on a horse was named Carl. I did. Khaleesi and Carl, they're going to make a happy pair.
是的。这个名字叫卡尔吗？不，是卡奥。哦，卡奥。我喜欢你认为那个不说英语、在马上赤裸上身的家伙叫卡尔。我确实这么认为。卡丽熙和卡奥，他们会成为幸福的一对。
Look at him riding off in the sunset. Carl, I was like, Carl, they only refer to him by his first and last name all the time. I have noticed that in two and a half episodes, he has only said the word no three times. It's because Carl can't speak English, Jenna. Okay. Well, that was it. Thank you for watching. That was it.
看着他骑马走向夕阳。卡尔，我当时想，卡尔，他们一直只用他的名字和姓氏称呼他。我注意到在两集半里，他只说了三次“不”这个词。那是因为卡奥不会说英语，珍娜。好吧。好吧，就是这样。谢谢你的观看。就是这样。
I gave in. I did it. I watched it. I'm a little bit hooked. Okay, good. You'll love all the White Walker stuff. Okay, I now, I guess, have to watch, what's it, The Edge with you?
我屈服了。我做到了。我看了它。我有点上瘾了。好吧，很好。你会喜欢所有异鬼的东西。好吧，我想，我必须和你一起看，是什么，边缘？
The Edge. The Edge. Have you never seen The Edge? We already, you already know this. But you've never seen it? How many different ways do you want me to tell you I haven't seen it? You know about the bear.
边缘。边缘。你从来没看过《边缘》吗？我们已经，你已经知道这个了。但你从来没看过它？你想让我用多少种不同的方式告诉你我没看过它？你知道关于熊的事。
How do you know about the bear? I've seen trailers. I've seen, you know what? All I needed to see was a man like getting attacked by a bear. And I'm like, I'm out. Also, Leo- So the Revenant was not for you either. Oh, hell no. Academy Award winning film, The Revenant.
你怎么知道关于熊的事？我看过预告片。我看过，你知道吗？我所需要看到的只是一个男人被熊攻击。我就想，我退出了。还有，莱奥——所以《荒野猎人》也不适合你。哦，绝对不。奥斯卡获奖电影，《荒野猎人》。
Oh, hell no. Another great survivalist film for all you survivalists out there. I saw a trailer and what's his name? Leo DiCaprio is getting mauled by a bear and he's like, pass, hard pass. All right. Well, you know I like quotes from things and I really appreciated this quote from Game of Thrones. I love that we're still talking about it. Go. The man who passes the sentence should swing the sword. Oh yeah. I liked that. And he made his son cut off that guy's head.
哦，绝对不。另一部伟大的生存主义电影，给你们所有的生存主义者。我看了预告片，他叫什么名字？莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥被熊抓伤了，他就像，放弃，坚决放弃。好吧。好吧，你知道我喜欢引用东西，我真的很欣赏《权力的游戏》里的这句名言。我喜欢我们还在谈论它。继续。执行死刑的人应该挥剑。哦是的。我喜欢那个。他让他儿子砍下了那个家伙的头。
No, he made him watch as he cut off the head. Well, eventually he makes him cut off someone's head. Wow. Spoiler alert. A bunch of people are going to lose their heads. It's part of life back then. OK, back then in fantasy land. There you go, guys.
不，他让他看着他砍下头。嗯，最终他让他砍下某人的头。哇。剧透警告。一群人要失去他们的头了。那是当时生活的一部分。OK，在奇幻世界里。给你，伙计们。
That was my fast fact number three. I promise after this break, we will begin talking about the office again, specifically The Carpet. We will break down the episode for you. I think Dwight would have loved Game of Thrones. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. I think him and Angela would have watched it.
那是我的快速事实第三条。我保证休息后，我们将开始再次谈论《办公室》，特别是《地毯》。我们将为你解析这一集。我想德怀特会喜欢《权力的游戏》。哦是的。哦是的。我想他和安吉拉会看的。
You guys would have spoken to one another in Dothraki. Oh, for sure. It would be like our code language. You have a somewhat Dothrakian relationship. A bit of a Cal-Khaleesi thing. You mean Carl? All right, let's go to break. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
你们会用多斯拉克语互相交谈。哦，当然。那会像我们的密码语言。你们有一种多斯拉克式的关系。有点卡奥-卡丽熙的感觉。你是说卡尔？好吧，让我们休息一下。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。
And this month, BetterHelp is giving you the biggest discount on starting therapy that they have ever offered on our show, with 90% off your first week. So here's how it works with BetterHelp you can pay a flat fee for weekly sessions and that's going to save you big time on cost and time because therapy should feel accessible and with online therapy you get quality care at a price that makes sense. And with over 30,000 therapists BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and has served over 5 million people globally.
这个月，BetterHelp为你提供了他们节目中提供的最大的开始治疗折扣，你的第一周有90%的折扣。所以BetterHelp的工作方式是，你可以为每周的课程支付固定费用，这将为你节省大量的时间和金钱，因为治疗应该是可及的，通过在线治疗，你可以以合理的价格获得高质量的护理。拥有超过30,000名治疗师，BetterHelp是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，已在全球服务超过500万人。
And it's convenient. You can join a session with a click of the button and it helps you to fit therapy into your busy life. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Your well-being is worth it. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 90% off your first week.
而且很方便。你可以点击按钮加入会议，它帮助你将治疗融入忙碌的生活。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时免费更换治疗师。你的幸福是值得的。今天访问betterhelp.com/officeladies，你的第一周可享受90%的折扣。
That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. With the FIZ loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply.
那是betterhelp, H-E-L-P点com/officeladies。通过FIZ忠诚度计划，你只需拥有移动套餐即可获得奖励。你知道，为了发短信之类的。如果你没有通过移动套餐获得额外数据和美元折扣等奖励，你就不是Fizz的用户。今天就切换。条件适用。
Details at Fizz.ca. When the frustration grows and the doubts start to creep in, we all need someone who has our back to tell us we'll be okay, to remind us of our ability to believe. Because their belief in us transfers to self belief and reminds us of all that we're capable of. We all need someone to make us believe. Hashtag, you got this. Okay, we're back from break.
详情请见Fizz.ca。当挫折感增加，怀疑开始潜入时，我们都需要一个支持我们的人告诉我们我们会没事的，提醒我们相信的能力。因为他们对我们的信念转化为自我信念，提醒我们我们所能做的一切。我们都需要有人让我们相信。标签，你做到了。好吧，我们休息回来了。
We start this episode with a cold open. Pam is on vacation. Yes. Ryan is at the reception desk and Jim keeps glancing up at Ryan and he's like, what are you looking at? And Ryan has that great talking head where he's like, Jim keeps looking over at reception. But it's not as creepy as the way Michael's looking at him. Yes, exactly.
我们以冷开场开始这一集。帕姆在度假。是的。瑞安在前台，吉姆一直抬头看着瑞安，他就像，你在看什么？瑞安有那个很棒的访谈片段，他说，吉姆一直看着前台。但这不像迈克尔看他的方式那么令人毛骨悚然。是的，完全正确。
Okay, so the episode starts and Pam is back from vacation. She's happy. She's at front reception. Michael walks in and calls her Spamster. Yeah. He hasn't done this bit in a while where he takes her name and smashes it with other things and she's like, let me guess how you got that Pam, Spam and Hamster. Spamster.
好吧，所以这一集开始了，帕姆度假回来了。她很开心。她在前台。迈克尔走进来，叫她Spamster。是的。他有一段时间没做这个把戏了，他把她的名字和其他东西混在一起，她就像，让我猜猜你是怎么得到那个的，帕姆，Spam和仓鼠。Spamster。
And then as he walks off, he goes, I am Pam Spicoli. You guys, for you young people, he's pretending to be Jeff Spicoli from Fast Times at Ridgemont High. Yeah, that's a dated reference. That is a dated reference. Michael goes in his office, what happens, Jenna? There's something very smelly on the carpet in his office.
然后当他走开时，他说，我是Pam Spicoli。伙计们，对于你们年轻人，他假装是《开放的美国学府》里的杰夫·斯皮科利。是的，那是一个过时的参考。那是一个过时的参考。迈克尔走进他的办公室，发生了什么，珍娜？他办公室的地毯上有一些非常臭的东西。
What I love about this is we don't ever show you too much of it. You see a little bit on the carpet in his office. What I love about this is we don't ever show you too much of it. You see a little bit on the carpet though, and what you see is foul. Yeah. It is so gross. It's pretty awful. And he makes a bunch of people come into the office to see what it is.
我喜欢这一点的是，我们从来没有向你展示太多。你在他办公室的地毯上看到了一点点。我喜欢这一点的是，我们从来没有向你展示太多。你确实在地毯上看到了一点点，你所看到的是恶臭的。是的。这太恶心了。这太糟糕了。他让一群人进办公室看看那是什么。
We had a fan question from David Griffiths and Haley Crook and many others. They wanted to know, was there anything in the office that made it actually smell so that we were having authentic reactions? No. That is just some good acting right there. Real good acting.
我们有一个来自大卫·格里菲斯和海莉·克鲁克以及许多其他人的粉丝问题。他们想知道，办公室里有什么东西让它真的发臭，以至于我们有真实的反应吗？没有。那只是很好的表演。真正的表演。
As I watched this, I was so impressed. I was so impressed. I actually texted Brian and I was like, I want you to go back and rewatch the carpet. When you get a whiff of whatever it is, it made me laugh so hard. I was like, I want you to go back and rewatch the carpet. When you get a whiff of whatever it is, it made me laugh so hard. I was like, he did such a great job. And Michael has a line, you guys,
当我观看这个时，我印象深刻。我印象深刻。我实际上给布莱恩发了短信，我说，我希望你回去重看《地毯》。当你闻到那是什么味道时，它让我笑得太厉害了。我当时想，我希望你回去重看《地毯》。当你闻到那是什么味道时，它让我笑得太厉害了。我当时想，他做得太棒了。迈克尔有一句台词，伙计们，
I feel like is sort of my vernacular, like the way I would talk. He says, there is a stink in there. That is how you would describe it. There's a stink y'all. And I love Creed's line. A lot of fans pointed this out. Someone making soup.
我觉得这有点像我的方言，就像我说话的方式。他说，里面有臭味。这就是你会描述它的方式。里面有臭味，伙计们。我喜欢克里德的台词。很多粉丝指出了这一点。有人在做汤。
Somebody making soup. So my sister Janet was visiting and watched this episode with me. She made me screen grab Phyllis's face reaction to when Creed says, somebody making soup. Seriously, it is hilarious. It's at three minutes, 10 seconds. Somebody making soup.
有人在做汤。所以我妹妹珍妮特来访，和我一起看了这一集。她让我截取了菲利斯对克里德说“有人在做汤”时的面部反应。说真的，这太搞笑了。在3分10秒。有人在做汤。
Look at Phyllis's face. Next we have Michael's talking head where he's talking about fear factor and he has to leave. And then for the rest of the episode, we're clearing out his office. I did a deep dive on fear factor. Why, Jenna? Why did I do a deep dive? I don't know. This has started to happen to us, where something's mentioned in an episode, and then we spend hours watching clips or researching things on websites. My gosh. It was like you watching all the videos of the Hooters' birthdays. Yeah.
看看菲利斯的脸。接下来是迈克尔的访谈片段，他在谈论《恐惧因素》，他必须离开。然后在那一集的其余时间里，我们在清理他的办公室。我深入研究了《恐惧因素》。为什么，珍娜？为什么我深入研究了？我不知道。这已经开始发生在我们身上了，当某件事在某一集中被提到，然后我们花几个小时看剪辑或在网站上研究东西。天哪。就像你看着所有胡特斯生日的视频一样。是的。
I watched these Fear Factor clips. You guys, it was like, okay, eat this dried horse rectum. I'm not kidding. Yeah. I'm not kidding. Or intestine or something. And then I looked up why it got canceled. Okay. I'm not kidding. Yeah. Or intestine or something. And then I looked up why it got canceled. Okay. It's so gross. What happened?
我看了那些《恐惧因素》的片段。伙计们，就像是，好吧，吃掉这个干马直肠。我没开玩笑。是的。我没开玩笑。或者是肠子之类的。然后我查了一下它为什么被取消。好吧。我没开玩笑。是的。或者是肠子之类的。然后我查了一下它为什么被取消。好吧。太恶心了。发生了什么？
I don't even think we can see it here. What happened? They had. It got canceled because of an incident? Yes. And they didn't air it, but it's why it got canceled. And Joe Rogan has talked about it. It's so gross.
我觉得我们甚至不能在这里看它。发生了什么？他们有。它被取消是因为一个事件？是的。他们没有播出，但这就是它被取消的原因。乔·罗根谈到过它。太恶心了。
What? Okay. You had two choices. This episode is called the Hee Haw episode. You could drink donkey pee or donkey semen. That is horrible, Jenna. That is horrible. Did they do it?
什么？好吧。你有两个选择。这一集叫“希哈”集。你可以喝驴尿或驴精液。那太可怕了，珍娜。那太可怕了。他们真的做了吗？
They did it. Oh! They did it. And one guy said as he started drinking, he vomited back in his own cup. Oh, God. It's horrible. Oh, my God. It's horrible. Oh my god. It's horrible. This was and how how did this get I mean who was like yeah that's a great idea that's also how did they get
他们做了。哦！他们做了。其中一个人说他开始喝的时候，吐回了自己的杯子里。哦，天哪。太可怕了。哦，天哪。太可怕了。哦，天哪。太可怕了。这到底是怎么回事，我是说谁会觉得“是的，这是个好主意”，还有他们是怎么弄到
the donkey jizz? Oh oh Angela. I'm sorry it's my first thought. Whose job was that? Wow. What job was that? Wow. Mm-hmm. No. No. No. I don't think so. No, not happening.
驴精的？哦，安吉拉。抱歉，这是我的第一反应。那是谁的工作？哇。那是什么工作？哇。嗯哼。不。不。不。我不这么认为。不，不可能发生。
Next up in the episode, wow, sorry, did everyone do it? Or just, like, what happens if you don't do it? You're out? I don't know, like, I know there, you know, there's the contest and if you do it, ultimately, whatever all the challenges are, I don't know how people get picked,
接下来在这一集中，哇，抱歉，每个人都做了吗？还是说，如果你不做会怎样？你被淘汰了？我不知道，就像，我知道那里，你知道，有比赛，如果你做了，最终，无论所有挑战是什么，我不知道人们是怎么被选中的，
but whoever does the challenge, if they don't do it, they're out. It was a crazy show, crazy. All right, I'm looking in the booth where Sam and Cody are sitting and everyone. They seem sad. I've ruined their day. You guys, I just, well, like this was such a big deal for Michael to, like, be like, this is
但无论谁参加挑战，如果他们不做，他们就出局了。那是一个疯狂的节目，疯狂。好了，我正在看山姆和科迪坐的那个隔间，每个人。他们看起来很悲伤。我毁了他们的一天。伙计们，我只是，好吧，这对于迈克尔来说是一件大事，就像，这是
my Fear Factor audition tape. I was like, oh yeah, what was that show again? I just started looking it up. That was, like, one of the first things that came up. Anyway, you're welcome. Where are we? So next up, Jim enters. He asks about Pam's vacation.
我的《恐惧因素》试镜带。我当时想，哦，是的，那是什么节目来着？我刚开始查。那是，就像，最先出现的事情之一。总之，不客气。我们到哪了？所以接下来，吉姆进来了。他问起帕姆的假期。
He is so excited that she's back at the reception desk. But then we reveal that Roy and Daryl are also upstairs and that Roy is, they're cleaning out Michael's office. They're gonna replace the carpet basically. And Pam and Roy are clearly on good terms. They're like giggly. They're giggly and Roy is like engaging with her. You know what I mean?
他非常兴奋她回到了接待台。但随后我们揭示了罗伊和达里尔也在楼上，罗伊正在，他们正在清理迈克尔的办公室。他们基本上要更换地毯。帕姆和罗伊显然关系很好。他们像是在傻笑。他们傻笑着，罗伊在和她互动。你知道我的意思吗？
He like looks over and mouth the word help, you know, cause he's got to go do this gross job and she laughs. So they're being kind of flirty and sweet and Jim clocks it right away. We had a fan question from Jamie Boggs, why on earth are the warehouse guys changing the carpet? How is that in their job description? I kind of agree, but it makes sense to me. I feel like Michael makes people do things outside of their job description all the time. And so we kind of had to do this too, just as a writing convention, we needed
他看了一眼，嘴里说着“救命”，你知道，因为他得去做这个恶心的工作，她笑了。所以他们表现得有点调情和甜蜜，吉姆立刻就察觉到了。我们有一个来自杰米·博格斯的粉丝提问，为什么仓库的人要换地毯？这怎么会在他们的工作职责里？我有点同意，但这对我来说说得通。我觉得迈克尔总是让人们做他们工作职责之外的事情。所以我们不得不这样做，只是作为一种写作惯例，我们需要
a reason for Roy to be upstairs for this whole episode. So we kind of need him to change the carpet. But a lot of people asked, did they really rip up and replace the carpet? Well, they did really rip it up. But I don't think they really replaced it. I think they just put it back down again in the end. Yeah, I think there was like a top carpet they pulled up. Yeah. But then they, yeah, exactly. Yeah, so, but they did. I mean, they really did dismantle the office in the middle of this shooting.
一个理由让罗伊在这一整集里都在楼上。所以我们有点需要他去换地毯。但很多人问，他们真的拆掉并更换了地毯吗？嗯，他们确实拆掉了。但我不认为他们真的更换了它。我想他们最后只是把它又铺回去了。是的，我想有一层顶层地毯他们拉起来了。是的。但后来他们，是的，没错。是的，所以，但他们确实做了。我是说，他们确实在拍摄过程中拆除了办公室。
Yes, and all of Michael's talking heads take place in the conference room. All of his stuff is piled behind him. Yes. So that's sort of a new spot where we see Michael. That was a fan question too from Alexandra. What is the room Michael has his talking heads in while his carpet is being cleaned? It's the conference room. I was curious too and so I zoomed in on the scene where Michael is talking and I realized it was the conference room because the painting is hanging on the wall behind him.
是的，迈克尔所有的“谈话头”镜头都是在会议室里拍摄的。他所有的东西都堆在他身后。是的。所以那是我们看到迈克尔的一个新地点。那也是亚历山德拉的一个粉丝提问。迈克尔在清理地毯时进行“谈话头”的房间是什么？是会议室。我也很好奇，所以我放大了迈克尔说话的场景，我意识到那是会议室，因为画挂在他身后的墙上。
It was the painting that was always in the conference room. I felt like that was a nice little touch to let the audience know where he was. At one point, it actually falls down. I noticed that. As they were banging around. That was a blooper. That was a blooper. That was not intended.
那是那幅一直挂在会议室里的画。我觉得这是一个很好的小细节，让观众知道他在哪里。有一次，它实际上掉下来了。我注意到了。当他们砰砰作响的时候。那是个失误。那是个失误。那不是故意的。
But it was a great just like kind of reminder like where he was. So next up, Michael takes over Jim's desk, forcing Jim into the annex. He's going to sit next to Kelly. She explains that Toby used to sit there, but he had to move due to an allergy. To the desk. To the annex. He's going to sit next to Kelly. She explains that Toby used to sit there, but he had to move due to an allergy. To the desk. To the desk. His allergy was to the desk. I'm pretty sure all those desks are the same desk, but Toby just had a specific allergy to that one. So then we have Michael in the bullpen, and he's chatting with Dwight. They're kind of talking about the old days. They start talking about Ed Truck, and you see that great flashback photo.
但这只是一个很好的提醒，提醒他在哪里。所以接下来，迈克尔接管了吉姆的办公桌，迫使吉姆去了附楼。他要坐在凯利旁边。她解释说托比以前坐在那里，但他因为过敏不得不搬走。对桌子。对附楼。他要坐在凯利旁边。她解释说托比以前坐在那里，但他因为过敏不得不搬走。对桌子。对桌子。他的过敏是对桌子。我很确定所有那些桌子都是一样的桌子，但托比只是对那一张有特定的过敏。所以接下来迈克尔在办公区，他正在和德怀特聊天。他们有点在谈论过去的日子。他们开始谈论埃德·卡车，你看到了那张很棒的闪回照片。
And the mullet haircut. Yeah. Also at five minutes, 12 seconds, Dwight is so happy that Michael is gonna be sitting next to him. He is just so thrilled. And I watched the deleted scenes for this episode, and there's a really cute talking head
还有那个鲻鱼头发型。是的。另外在5分12秒，德怀特非常高兴迈克尔要坐在他旁边。他真是太激动了。我看了这一集的删减片段，有一个非常可爱的“谈话头”
where Dwight is like, this is just a gift. The woman I'm dating might say it's a gift from God, but I don't know about that. And it cuts to me. But there are some great deleted scenes for this episode. If you have the DVDs and I have a talking head, Kevin has a really funny one. There's a deleted scene, you guys, where Jim is looking up the hotel where Pam and Roy stayed in the Poconos. Oh, that's a little depressing. I know. And Kelly's like, what are you looking at?
德怀特说，这简直是天赐之物。我约会的那个女人可能会说这是上帝的礼物，但我不知道。然后切到了我。但这一集有一些很棒的删减片段。如果你有DVD，我有一个“谈话头”，凯文有一个非常有趣的。有一个删减片段，伙计们，吉姆正在查帕姆和罗伊在波科诺斯住的酒店。哦，那有点令人沮丧。我知道。凯利说，你在看什么？
There's also a deleted scene where he's eating alone in his car. Oh yeah, because he can't find anywhere to eat. Exactly, exactly. But there is some really sweet Dwight Angela little nods to that relationship in the deleted scenes. And also during this whole Dwight-Michael moment, we learn that Dwight is sitting where Todd Packer used to sit,
还有一个删减片段是他独自在车里吃饭。哦，是的，因为他找不到吃饭的地方。没错，没错。但在删减片段中，德怀特和安吉拉对那段关系有一些非常甜蜜的点头。而且在整个德怀特和迈克尔的时刻，我们了解到德怀特坐在托德·帕克以前坐的地方，
and Michael is sitting in his old desk, because Ed Trek would have been in his office. So Michael is having a little bit of like reliving the glory days of when he was out on the floor as salesman. Yes. I think we have some real Stanley sass in this episode. Stanley sass. Yes, at seven minutes, one second, Michael bugs Stanley.
而迈克尔坐在他以前的办公桌上，因为埃德·卡车以前会在他的办公室里。所以迈克尔有点像是在重温他作为推销员在外面工作时的辉煌岁月。是的。我认为我们在这一集中看到了一些真正的斯坦利傲慢。斯坦利傲慢。是的，在7分01秒，迈克尔烦扰斯坦利。
And Stanley is on the phone. And this is what Stanley says to him. I just loved it. Leslie David Baker did such an amazing job. What is it that you need right now that can't wait until I'm off the phone with a customer? I was like, there's some Stanley sass. So Michael is now walking around the bullpen and he's just really misbehaving. He's like acting out in some way. He thinks maybe
斯坦利正在打电话。这就是斯坦利对他说的。我太喜欢了。莱斯利·大卫·贝克做得太棒了。你现在需要什么不能等到我跟客户打完电话再说？我当时想，这就是斯坦利的傲慢。所以迈克尔现在在办公区走来走去，他真的表现得很糟糕。他以某种方式表现出来。他认为也许
they were all in on it, but yet also I think he's trying to live his glory days. He just punches the heck out of Creed. Oh, I loved Creed's reaction to that though. It was so earnest. It's like one of the few times he's truly earnest. He's like, ow, why'd you hit me, Michael? Like it actually really hurt him. And Michael, as he punched him, yelled, Charlie horse. He's like a kid on a playground, basically. He's like a bad kid on a playground,
他们都参与其中，但同时我也认为他是在试图重温他的辉煌岁月。他只是狠狠地打了克里德一拳。哦，但我喜欢克里德对此的反应。太真诚了。这是他真正真诚的少数几次之一。他说，哎哟，你为什么打我，迈克尔？就像它真的让他很疼。迈克尔在打他的时候喊道：“查理马！”他基本上就像操场上的孩子。他就像操场上一个坏孩子，
but that's not a Charlie horse. Punching someone isn't a Charlie horse. You know what a Charlie horse is. That's just when your muscle seizes up? Well, yeah, but I think what he's trying to say is like, how does a horse bite an apple? Wait, what? Stop. Stop the podcast.
但那不是查理马。打人不是查理马。你知道什么是查理马。那是当你的肌肉抽筋的时候？嗯，是的，但我认为他想说的是，马是怎么咬苹果的？等等，什么？停下。停止播客。
What? How's a horse bite an apple? Is that like Charlie horse just hitting someone or is he hitting someone to give him a Charlie horse? What is how's a horse bite an apple? Come over here. I'll show you. No, no, no, no, no.
什么？马是怎么咬苹果的？那是像查理马那样打人，还是他打人是为了给对方一个查理马？什么是“马是怎么咬苹果的”？过来。我给你演示一下。不，不，不，不，不。
Explain. What is this? This is a thing you do to a person on a playground is called how's a horse bite an apple? Yeah, how's a horse bite an apple? Come over here, I'll show you. No, no, no, no, no. Explain. What is this? This is a thing you do to a person on a playground is called how's a horse bite an apple? Yeah, how's a horse bite an apple? I'm gonna show you. I'm scared. What are you reaching for right now? You're reaching for what?
解释一下。这是什么？这是你在操场上对人做的一件事，叫“马是怎么咬苹果的”。是的，马是怎么咬苹果的？过来。我给你演示一下。不，不，不，不，不。解释一下。这是什么？这是你在操场上对人做的一件事，叫“马是怎么咬苹果的”。是的，马是怎么咬苹果的？我要给你演示。我很害怕。你现在在伸手拿什么？你在伸手拿什么？
My arm, my hand? What are you reaching for? I'm not that strong. It's not gonna hurt that bad. If Josh did it to you, he has strong hands. Okay, what am I doing? What am I handing you? You gotta slide over here.
我的胳膊，我的手？你在伸手拿什么？我没那么强壮。不会那么疼的。如果乔什对你做，他手劲很大。好吧，我在做什么？我在递给你什么？你得滑过来。
Slide over to what? My chair. Why? What are you touching? Okay, back up. What? What are I doing? What am I handing you? You gotta slide over here. Slide over to what? My chair. Why? What are you touching? Okay, back up. What? Don't do, what are you doing?
滑到什么地方？我的椅子。为什么？你在摸什么？好吧，退后。什么？我在做什么？我在递给你什么？你得滑过来。滑到什么地方？我的椅子。为什么？你在摸什么？好吧，退后。什么？别做，你在做什么？
It's not gonna hurt that bad. How's a horse bite an apple? What? Oh, that thing where you just like, where you squeeze someone's knee. The top of their knee and that two little spots that really hurt. I don't think that hurts. I think that's tickly. That's how a horse bites an apple.
不会那么疼的。马是怎么咬苹果的？什么？哦，就是那种你捏某人膝盖的东西。膝盖顶部那两个真的很疼的小点。我不觉得那很疼。我觉得那是痒痒的。那就是马咬苹果的方式。
Am I right, Sam? I've never heard how a horse bites an apple. What is going on, St. Louis? St. Louis. St. Louis, you check. Back me up. Where I was raised. Do we have horses that bite the apple?
我说得对吗，山姆？我从来没听说过马是怎么咬苹果的。到底怎么回事，圣路易斯？圣路易斯。圣路易斯，你查一下。支持我。我长大的地方。我们有马咬苹果吗？
This, come on. I don't know how to react to it. Sam. Sam seems to have heard this. Yeah, that made its way to Wisconsin. Wisconsin has How's a Horse Bites an Apple. Cody, where are you from? Have you heard it? I'm from here, but my grandma was from Kansas and my grandpa was from Tennessee and I've
这，拜托。我不知道该怎么反应。山姆。山姆似乎听说过这个。是的，它传到了威斯康星州。威斯康星州有“马是怎么咬苹果的”。科迪，你是哪里人？你听说过吗？我是本地人，但我奶奶是堪萨斯人，我爷爷是田纳西人，我
never heard that. Thank you. Okay. So Missouri, Kansas and Tennessee, we don't know this horse bites and apple business. Well, Texas and Wisconsin do. This is based on a poll of four people, by the way. We've declared things about major regions of the United States based on a four-person poll.
从来没听说过。谢谢。好吧。所以密苏里、堪萨斯和田纳西，我们不知道这个马咬苹果的勾当。嗯，德克萨斯和威斯康星知道。顺便说一句，这是基于四个人的民意调查。我们基于四个人的民意调查宣布了关于美国主要地区的事情。
That seems, I think that's kind of how polling is done though. Oh, let's not go there. Okay. Well, Charlie horse is just when your muscle seizes up. I know that, but I kind of felt like it was like one of those things where Michael gets it a little wrong. Like, he's like, Charlie horse, but I was like, Oh, did he mean, how's a horse bite an apple?
这看起来，我认为这确实是民意调查的方式。哦，我们别谈这个了。好吧。嗯，查理马只是当你的肌肉抽筋的时候。我知道，但我有点觉得这就像迈克尔有点弄错的事情之一。就像，他说，查理马，但我当时想，哦，他是指“马是怎么咬苹果的”吗？
But probably not because that's too many words and he had to cross the whole room really quickly. Um, well, Michael also gets Dwight to go over to accounting and dump their stuff all over the ground. We had a fan question from Alan three. How many times did Stephen Rain mess up the accounting area? Did they do it randomly or was it choreographed? Angela, can you give us some insight? We did it a few times and you know so every time Michael would say, okay let's send up accounting, old-fashioned raid, sells on accounting, they would come over, they'd dump all
但可能不是，因为那字数太多了，他必须很快穿过整个房间。嗯，迈克尔还让德怀特去会计部把他们的东西全倒在地上。我们有一个来自艾伦三的粉丝提问。斯蒂芬·雷恩把会计区弄乱了多少次？他们是随机做的还是编排好的？安吉拉，你能给我们一些见解吗？我们做了几次，你知道，所以每次迈克尔都会说，好吧，让我们派会计部上去，老式突袭，会计部，他们会过来，他们会把
of our stuff on the floor. I did love that Angela glares at Dwight like don't even. And so he sort of giggles and picks up one pencil and throws it on the floor of mine. But yeah, we did that a few times and they were just really truly just look like Steve and Rain were having fun because they got to come over and mess with us. And then so after you shoot a scene like that and they mess up the area, they say cut. Did the set decorators come over and reset everything? They do because they want the continuity to match. Yeah.
我们的东西全倒在地板上。我确实喜欢安吉拉瞪着德怀特，好像在说“想都别想”。所以他有点傻笑，捡起一支铅笔扔在我的地板上。但是的，我们做了几次，他们看起来真的很开心，因为他们可以过来捉弄我们。然后，在你拍摄完这样的场景，他们把区域弄乱之后，他们喊“卡”。布景装饰师会过来重置一切吗？他们会，因为他们希望连续性匹配。是的。
And obviously we would pick up stuff as well, but sometimes we would get in the way. We would start to pick it up and they'd be like, here, let me set that. Because that is their job to make sure it looks exactly like it did before. And I might not get it right. So I remember sometimes before scenes like this, our script supervisor, Veda, she is
显然我们也会捡东西，但有时我们会碍事。我们会开始捡，他们会说，来，让我来设置。因为那是他们的工作，确保它看起来和以前一模一样。我可能做不对。所以我记得有时在这样的场景之前，我们的剧本主管维达，她是
the person who was in charge of continuity on the show. She would come over and take a picture of the desk area as a reference point. So they could match it each time. Yes. And then after it got all messed up, then Veda would come over with her computer and she'd be like, okay, so this is exactly where the cup was and this is where this was and everything. And they would reset the whole thing to Veda's picture and mess it up again. Yes. Veda was amazing and she was so sweet and kind and soft spoken. And sometimes she would just
负责节目连续性的人。她会过来拍一张办公桌区域的照片作为参考点。这样他们每次都能匹配。是的。然后当它被弄乱后，维达会带着她的电脑过来，她会说，好吧，所以杯子就在这里，这个就在这里，一切都在这里。他们会根据维达的照片重置整个东西，然后再弄乱它。是的。维达太棒了，她非常甜美、善良、说话轻声细语。有时她会
walk up to you and be like, um, Angela, and on the second line in the scene, you switched your coffee mug from your left hand to your right hand. I'm like, oh my God, did I? I didn't even realize, yes. So you have to do that every time now. Yes, I remember that. I remember that. At eight minutes, 55 seconds, I'm calling this the fan catch of the day. What is it?
走到你面前说，嗯，安吉拉，在场景的第二行，你把咖啡杯从左手换到了右手。我说，哦，天哪，我换了吗？我甚至没意识到，是的。所以你现在每次都得那样做。是的，我记得。我记得。在8分55秒，我称之为当天的粉丝捕捉。是什么？
It is by Biro. If you freeze and zoom in on Angela's computer, ooh, you can see a Post-it note that says, quote, Angela, can I have $5 petty cash to buy some more jelly beans? I'll give you back any change. Thanks, Pam. Catch of the day. That is fantastic. I loved that.
是比罗。如果你暂停并放大安吉拉的电脑，哦，你可以看到一张便利贴，上面写着，引用，“安吉拉，我能要5美元零用钱去买些软糖吗？我会把剩下的零钱还给你。谢谢，帕姆。”当天的捕捉。太棒了。我喜欢那个。
Applause. I think I really wrote that post-it note. You probably did. You probably passed it to me in the background because we were bored and I stuck it there. So then Michael has a talking head about former manager Ed Truck. And this has one of my favorite Michael quotes. I told myself if I was ever manager, people would laugh when they saw me coming and applaud when I walked away.
掌声。我想我真的写了那张便利贴。你可能写了。你可能在后台把它递给了我，因为我们很无聊，我就把它贴在那里了。所以迈克尔有一个关于前任经理埃德·卡车的“谈话头”。这有我最喜欢的迈克尔名言之一。我告诉自己，如果我当了经理，人们看到我来时会笑，我走开时会鼓掌。
Mission accomplished. Yeah, way to go. I just want to call out one scene, you guys. I know we're jumping around a little, but it's one I absolutely love at 9 minutes 55 seconds. It made me laugh so hard when Dwight is trying to be the 107th caller. Yes! To win a DVD box set.
任务完成。是的，干得好。我只想提一个场景，伙计们。我知道我们跳来跳去，但在9分55秒有一个我绝对喜欢的场景。当德怀特试图成为第107个打电话的人时，我笑得太厉害了。是的！去赢取一套DVD盒装。
Of Jethro Tull. Yes! From Rock 107. And he just keeps calling. And Michael's pained expression. And then Dwight trying to sneak the call. All of it just cracked me up. One of the fun dynamics about the Michael and Dwight relationship is that it gives Steve
杰思罗·塔尔的。是的！来自摇滚107。他一直打。迈克尔痛苦的表情。然后德怀特试图偷偷打电话。所有这些都让我笑得前仰后合。迈克尔和德怀特关系中一个有趣的动态是，它给了史蒂夫
an opportunity to play the straight man. Yeah. And he's a very funny straight man. And so a lot of times he's the funny guy. And the rest of us are the straight man to Steve. But I love this dynamic shift that happens with Michael and Dwight scenes. I do too. I want you to know I did a little bit of a deep dive for Rock 107. I knew you would. I almost did. But you know what I did instead?
一个扮演直男的机会。是的。他是一个非常有趣的直男。所以很多时候他是那个有趣的人。而我们其他人是史蒂夫的直男。但我喜欢迈克尔和德怀特场景中发生的这种动态转变。我也喜欢。我想让你知道，我为摇滚107做了一点深入调查。我知道你会的。我差点也做了。但你知道我做了什么吗？
What? I listened to Jethro Tull. Oh, there you go. I downloaded the greatest hits and listened to it and my daughter Isabel was like, what is that? Well, they currently run contests via their freeloaders club. And you can sign up with your email at rock107.com and they give away, quote, dozens of prizes each month.
什么？我听了杰思罗·塔尔。哦，原来如此。我下载了精选集并听了它，我女儿伊莎贝尔说，那是什么？嗯，他们目前通过他们的“免费加载者俱乐部”举办比赛。你可以在rock107.com用你的电子邮件注册，他们每月赠送，引用，“数十个奖品”。
Here's a list of things you can win. Okay. iPads, waterpark tickets, concert tickets, gas and grocery gifts, and snow tube passes. Maybe for the Poconos? Maybe. Those are great gifts, though. I know. Way to go, Rock 107.
这是一份你可以赢取的物品清单。好吧。iPad、水上乐园门票、演唱会门票、汽油和杂货礼品，以及雪圈通行证。也许是去波科诺斯的？也许吧。不过那些是很棒的礼物。我知道。干得好，摇滚107。
It seems like instead of doing these live contests on the air where you have to call in like Dwight did, you can just sign up with your email and you're automatically entered. So just giving a plug for that giveaway, Rock 107. Way to go. I have 10 minutes, 44 seconds. Okay. Pam and Roy are flirting at reception and Jim is watching her in the kitchen.
看起来与其在广播中进行这些现场比赛，你必须像德怀特那样打电话，你只需要用你的电子邮件注册，你就自动参加了。所以只是为那个赠品做个广告，摇滚107。干得好。我有10分44秒。好吧。帕姆和罗伊在接待处调情，吉姆在厨房里看着她。
He tries to go to the annex, but he sees Kelly. Then he goes to the bathroom. With his coffee mug. Yeah. This is how trapped he is. One way is Pam and Roy, the other way it's Kelly chatty chatty chatty. So he just walks in the bathroom with his coffee mug.
他试图去附楼，但他看到了凯利。然后他去了洗手间。带着他的咖啡杯。是的。这就是他被困的程度。一边是帕姆和罗伊，另一边是凯利喋喋不休。所以他只是带着咖啡杯走进了洗手间。
Yeah. And later he can't eat in the lunch room because Pam's sitting in there with Roy. This leads to the deleted scene you were talking about. Him eating alone in his car. Yeah. Poor Jim, guys, poor Jim. Poor Jim.
是的。后来他不能在午餐室吃饭，因为帕姆和罗伊坐在那里。这导致了你刚才说的那个删减片段。他独自在车里吃饭。是的。可怜的吉姆，伙计们，可怜的吉姆。可怜的吉姆。
So then at 11 minutes, seven seconds, Michael goes back to accounting and he's like, hey guys, and I'm really snarky. This is like very Angela Martin snarky moment. I'm like, we haven't finished getting things in order from your last visit. And he's like, I'm just walking around and I go, were you? Like, I'm so ticked off.
所以然后在11分07秒，迈克尔回到会计部，他说，嘿伙计们，我真的很刻薄。这就像非常安吉拉·马丁式的刻薄时刻。我说，我们还没处理完你上次访问留下的烂摊子。他说，我只是走走，我说，你是吗？就像，我太生气了。
You're so mad. Well, this is when Michael gets this big idea to host a sales contest. Well, listen, because he says we're all there working for the weekend, but you know what? He's working for the week. What? Working for the week. He's working for the week, and he wants the sales contest now. And the prize is a $100 bill. Not really. Until he opens his wallet and he only has $83. Wait Jenna, before we get into the sales competition, I do have some journal entries from this. When do you want them? Do you want them
你太生气了。嗯，这是迈克尔想出举办销售竞赛这个大主意的时候。嗯，听着，因为他说我们都在那里为周末工作，但你知道吗？他是在为这一周工作。什么？为这一周工作。他是在为这一周工作，他现在想要销售竞赛。奖金是一张100美元的钞票。并不是真的。直到他打开钱包，他只有83美元。等等，珍娜，在我们进入销售竞赛之前，我确实有一些关于这个的日记条目。你什么时候想要它们？你想要它们
now? No. Do you want them now? I say now. Now, not leos. Okay. Here's my journal entry for the carpet. I was really excited. I was like, I wrote this on January 26, 2006. We got great news. We're coming back for season three. Is this the episode where we found out? Yes. Oh my gosh. So we were so excited, all of us. I don't know if you can tell in watching the episode, but we just found out we got another job for another year. That is such, that's a fast fact, Angela, right there.
现在吗？不。你现在想要它们吗？我说现在。现在，不是利奥。好吧。这是我关于地毯的日记条目。我真的很兴奋。我写道，2006年1月26日。我们得到了好消息。我们要回来拍第三季了。这是我们发现的那一集吗？是的。哦，天哪。所以我们非常兴奋，我们所有人。我不知道你在看这一集时能不能看出来，但我们刚刚发现我们又得到了一份工作，又拍一年。那是一个快速事实，安吉拉，就在那里。
Oh, well, I liked your Game of Thrones fast fact. But there, that I guess is a fast fact. Also, I said that we're just so excited. We're really proud of the show. We're so excited to get a third year. I said this week also, we had a photographer from NBC taking official photos for the website for Valentine's Day. I remember those photos.
哦，好吧，我喜欢你的《权力的游戏》快速事实。但那个，我想是一个快速事实。另外，我说我们太兴奋了。我们真的为这个节目感到自豪。我们非常兴奋能得到第三年。我说这一周我们还有一位来自NBC的摄影师为情人节拍摄官方照片。我记得那些照片。
These are sort of some iconic photos that are out there on the internet of like Steve holding up a heart and Kate Flannery and you and me and Phyllis all surrounding him. So there's some great Valentine's shot. There's one of like Dwight and I side by side. I did some photos with David Denman as Roy. So some Pam and Roy Valentine's shots as well. And I also wrote, this was the first time the supporting cast were included in one of
这些是互联网上流传的一些标志性照片，比如史蒂夫举着一颗心，凯特·弗兰纳里，你，我和菲利斯都围着他。所以有一些很棒的情人节照片。有一张我和德怀特并排的照片。我和大卫·丹曼作为罗伊拍了一些照片。所以也有一些帕姆和罗伊的情人节照片。我还写道，这是配角第一次被包括在其中
these big photo shoots and we were all so excited. I remember that. Because we weren't series regular the last time we did them. But now we were and we got to be in the pictures. And I said, of course, I had the biggest zit since I've had since high school. Yeah, that always happens. They probably Photoshopped about now.
这些大型照片拍摄中，我们都太兴奋了。我记得。因为我们上次拍的时候不是系列常驻演员。但现在我们是了，我们能出现在照片里。我说，当然，我有自高中以来最大的痘痘。是的，总是这样。他们现在可能用Photoshop修掉了。
I hope they'll Photoshop it now. See, look at that, like I said. I know. Anyway, those are. Oh, and then I wrote, and this is before, obviously, we ever knew we'd do this podcast. We ever knew that we'd be tracking the Mindy of it all. And this is what I wrote in 2006.
我希望他们现在会用Photoshop修掉它。看，就像我说的。我知道。总之，那些是。哦，然后我写道，这显然是在我们知道我们会做这个播客之前。我们知道我们会追踪明迪的一切。这就是我在2006年写的。
OK. If you're a Kelly fan, you will love this episode. And Mindy, who plays Kelly, does a great job. Hey. Even you knew something special is happening with the character of Kelly in the carpet. 2006 me knew that Kelly was maybe Kelly was maybe Mindy. All right, let's take a break. We'll be back in a sec.
好的。如果你是凯利粉丝，你会喜欢这一集的。扮演凯利的明迪做得很好。嘿。甚至你也知道凯利这个角色在地毯那一集里发生了一些特别的事情。2006年的我知道凯利可能是明迪。好了，我们休息一下。我们一会儿回来。
Roll Up to Win is back at Tim Hortons and you've got a shot at millions of prizes like the all new, all electric, 2025 Volkswagen ID Buzz. Play on the Tim's app until March 23rd. Rules apply Canada only. No purchase necessary. Visit the Tim's app for details. This episode is brought to you by RBC Student Banking. POV, you're learning you can get $100 when you open a no monthly fee
“滚动赢取”在蒂姆霍顿斯回归了，你有机会赢取数百万奖品，比如全新的、全电动的2025年大众ID Buzz。在3月23日前在蒂姆APP上玩。规则适用，仅限加拿大。无需购买。访问蒂姆APP了解详情。本集由RBC学生银行赞助。POV，你了解到当你开设一个无月费的
RBC Advantage Banking account. Plus, you get unlimited debit transactions in Canada and you can earn Avion points on debit purchases so you can vibe more with friends. POV. You're unlocking more perks for less with RBC. Conditions apply. Offer ends July 2nd, 2025. New eligible clients only. Complete criteria by August 29th, 2025. Visit rbc.com slash student 100. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game. Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial habits.
RBC优势银行账户时，你可以获得100美元。此外，你在加拿大可以获得无限的借记交易，并且你可以在借记购买中赚取Avion积分，这样你就可以和朋友们有更多共鸣。POV。你正在用RBC以更少的钱解锁更多的福利。条件适用。优惠于2025年7月2日结束。仅限新的合格客户。在2025年8月29日前完成标准。访问rbc.com/student100。你在还清账单吗？战胜你的月供。听起来你在财务游戏中处于领先地位。用BMO Eclipse Rise Visa卡提升自己。这张信用卡奖励你良好的财务习惯。
Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. All right, so back to the episode. I have a continuity catch. Okay. At 12 minutes, 43 seconds, Roy and Daryl are removing Michael's carpet.
每月全额且按时支付信用卡账单即可赚取积分。从账单支付者升级为奖励杀手。条款和条件适用。好了，回到这一集。我有一个连续性捕捉。好吧。在12分43秒，罗伊和达里尔正在移除迈克尔的地毯。
Okay, they've got this rolled up carpet on their shoulders and they make fun of his dancing. But then at 13 minutes, 12 seconds, there's a shot of them through the blinds in Michael's office and they're having beers and they're kind of sleeping. They're sleeping on the rolled up carpet that they just removed.
好吧，他们把卷起来的地毯扛在肩上，他们取笑他的舞蹈。但在13分12秒，有一个通过迈克尔办公室百叶窗拍摄的镜头，他们在喝啤酒，他们有点在睡觉。他们睡在他们刚刚移除的卷起来的地毯上。
They're using it as a headrest. Yeah. Well, there's a continuity catch. Well, I- Unless, is that the new carpet they haven't put down yet? I don't know, but there is a whole deleted scene of just Darryl and Roy just being idiots in that room. There's a whole scene where they are drinking beers and they have two like rubber balls and they're bouncing them against the wall. Like they've got a game going. Yeah. So there were things cut out of this episode of them messing around in there.
他们把它当作头枕。是的。嗯，这是一个连续性捕捉。嗯，我——除非，那是他们还没铺上的新地毯？我不知道，但有一个关于达里尔和罗伊在那个房间里当白痴的完整删减片段。有一个完整的场景，他们喝着啤酒，他们有两个像橡胶球一样的东西，他们把它们对着墙弹。就像他们在玩游戏一样。是的。所以这一集里剪掉了一些他们在里面胡闹的东西。
Well, I suppose it could be the carpet they haven't installed yet. Maybe. Maybe, Jenna. At 13 minutes, 56 seconds, I declare Michael Sass. Michael Sass, let's hear it. Well, Pam says stopping the sales contest isn't fair. I guess we should say Michael gets upset and he stops his sales contest
嗯，我想那可能是他们还没安装的地毯。也许吧。也许吧，珍娜。在13分56秒，我宣布迈克尔傲慢。迈克尔傲慢，让我们听听。嗯，帕姆说停止销售竞赛不公平。我想我们应该说迈克尔生气了，他停止了他的销售竞赛
No one can win $83 anymore. He's just being a brat, but Michael gives it right back to Pam Oh, yeah. Yeah, I didn't write down what he said, but you can look it up at 13 minutes 56 seconds If you want that sort of takes the wind out of it does I realize I was looking at my sheet I was like, wow, that was an incomplete, I did not complete that question of my homework. Oh, well, I will say this. My sister and I laughed actually. She's a school teacher.
没有人能再赢83美元了。他只是在耍小孩子脾气，但迈克尔直接回击了帕姆。哦，是的。是的，我没写下他说的话，但如果你想要的话，可以在13分56秒查一下。这有点让它泄气了。确实。我意识到我正在看我的表格，我当时想，哇，那是不完整的，我没有完成家庭作业的那个问题。哦，好吧，我会说这个。我和我姐姐实际上笑了。她是学校老师。
She teaches pre-K and at 14 minutes, 26 seconds, Michael puts the whole office in time out. Oh yes, oh yes. Anyway, okay. So then we have the scene in the kitchen with Jim and Ryan, and Jim asks Ryan what he thinks of Kelly. He's trying to help Kelly out because she's begged him. Well this also just shows where he's at in his day because at first he doesn't want to
她教预科班，在14分26秒，迈克尔让整个办公室暂停。哦，是的，哦，是的。总之，好吧。所以接下来我们在厨房里有吉姆和瑞恩的场景，吉姆问瑞恩对凯利有什么看法。他试图帮助凯利，因为她求过他。嗯，这也显示了他这一天的情况，因为起初他不想
help her. He's like, I'm not getting in the middle of those two. And then by the end of the day, he's like, fine, I'll be your go between because he doesn't have his buddy. He doesn't have Pam to help the day pass. Well, we had a fan question. Maddie W. and Adrienne both asked, whose idea was it for Kelly to have a crush on Ryan? What do you think, Angie?
帮助她。他说，我不会卷入他们两个之间。然后到了一天结束时，他说，好吧，我会做你们的中间人，因为他没有他的伙伴。他没有帕姆来帮助度过这一天。嗯，我们有一个粉丝提问。麦迪·W和阿德里安都问，凯利暗恋瑞恩是谁的主意？你觉得呢，安吉？
I think it was Mindy's. I don't know. I was going to text her, but she had the Oscars and she was presenting. I didn't want to bug her. Yeah. We were prepping this episode the weekend of Oscars and she was presenting. I didn't want to bug her. Yeah, we were, we were prepping this episode, the weekend of Oscars weekend. Yes. And Mindy was a presenter. And can we talk for one second about how amazing she looked in her dress?
我觉得是明迪的。我不知道。我本来要给她发短信，但她有奥斯卡颁奖典礼，她在颁奖。我不想打扰她。是的。我们在奥斯卡周末准备这一集，她在颁奖。我不想打扰她。是的，我们，我们在准备这一集，奥斯卡周末。是的。明迪是颁奖嘉宾。我们能谈谈她穿那件礼服看起来有多惊艳吗？
She looked amazing. I actually did text her and BJ the next day and I was like, you guys look so beautiful together. Yeah. And she wrote back, and I love this. Thank you. Well, there you go. Kelly and Ryan went to the Oscars together Well, they're very very dear friend their best friend their best friend There were a lot of friendships that came out of our show. There was our best friendship There was their best friendship. Well, all of the guys still play fantasy football together. That's all the guys every year
她看起来太棒了。我第二天确实给他们俩发了短信，我说，你们在一起看起来太美了。是的。她回信了，我喜欢这个。谢谢。好吧，就是这样。凯利和瑞恩一起去了奥斯卡。嗯，他们是非常非常亲爱的朋友，他们最好的朋友，他们最好的朋友。我们的节目中产生了很多友谊。有我们的友谊，有他们的友谊。嗯，所有的男士仍然一起玩梦幻足球。那是所有男士每年
All right. So where are we at Jenna? so next Michael talks to Creed about his fear of becoming Ed Truck. Oh, this scene is so funny. Creed made me laugh so hard in this scene. Yeah. He's like, Michael, you have a lot more
好了。所以我们到哪了，珍娜？所以接下来迈克尔和克里德谈论他害怕成为埃德·卡车。哦，这个场景太有趣了。克里德在这个场景里让我笑得太厉害了。是的。他说，迈克尔，你有很多
to be worried about than that. He's like, oh great, thanks Creed, I guess being buried alive, why am I even talking to you? And then we go outside and we meet Ed Truck. And this scene, ugh, it broke my heart because in the scene, Ed says, Michael, why can't your workers be your workers, your family be your family, and your friends be your friends? And you can see they hold on Michael's face. And you can see that the reason why is because he doesn't have friends and family.
比那更值得担心的事。他说，哦，太好了，谢谢克里德，我想被活埋，我为什么要和你说话？然后我们走到外面，见到了埃德·卡车。这个场景，呃，它让我心碎，因为在场景中，埃德说，迈克尔，为什么你的员工不能是你的员工，你的家人不能是你的家人，你的朋友不能是你的朋友？你可以看到他们停在迈克尔的脸上。你可以看到原因是因为他没有朋友和家人。
He needs his workers to be all three things. He doesn't have those compartments in his life. No, he doesn't. And it breaks your heart. It breaks your heart for him. Oh, well, speaking of heartbreak, 17 minutes, eight seconds. So this is like cut in between Michael's talking head.
他需要他的员工成为这三者。他的生活中没有那些隔间。不，他没有。这让你心碎。这让你为他心碎。哦，好吧，说到心碎，17分08秒。所以这就像在迈克尔的“谈话头”之间剪辑。
Jim is in the kitchen, which is kind of looks like Jim hung out in the kitchen all day. I think he spent a lot of time in there. Not only that guys, but if you look at this episode, John didn't have very many lines. This was not a tough like line count for him as far as like memory work. All of his stuff was reacting for the most part
吉姆在厨房里，看起来吉姆整天都在厨房里闲逛。我想他在那里花了很多时间。不仅如此，伙计们，如果你看这一集，约翰没有多少台词。对于他来说，这并不是一个艰难的台词量，就记忆工作而言。他大部分的东西都是反应
in this episode. So, but anyway, during Michael's talking head, we see Jim is in the kitchen and he tries to wave goodbye to Pam. Pam doesn't see it and just leaves. And it's like the last just like wind out of his sails for the day. She kind of leaves early. She's got her big puffy coat on and everyone else is still working, but she sneaks out. Yeah.
在这一集中。所以，但总之，在迈克尔的“谈话头”期间，我们看到吉姆在厨房里，他试图向帕姆挥手告别。帕姆没看见，直接走了。这就像他这一天最后的一点动力。她有点早退了。她穿着她那件大大的蓬松外套，其他人还在工作，但她溜走了。是的。
And what does he do after that? He calls Brenda. Oh God, it's so desperate. From Booz Cruise, the corporate liaison and asks her on a date. And Kelly's, Mindy's reactions as Kelly to this phone call were so fantastic. So great.
那之后他做了什么？他给布伦达打了电话。哦，天哪，太绝望了。来自“酒醉游轮”的那个企业联络员，并约她出去。凯利，明迪作为凯利对这个电话的反应太棒了。太棒了。
He calls and asks her on a date and then he's like, and you can just, you know, I got your number from the company directory and I guess you could get my number from the company directory. From said directory. Oh, what are you doing, Jim? Or check your email because I just emailed you.
他打电话约她出去，然后他说，你可以，你知道，我从公司名录里得到了你的号码，我想你可以从公司名录里得到我的号码。从上述名录。哦，你在做什么，吉姆？或者检查你的电子邮件，因为我刚给你发了邮件。
Okay, hope to hear from you. Okay. Yeah, and Kelly's like, did you just ask a girl out over voicemail? He's like, yep. Michael's talking head in this episode, he has a huge talking head that I love and I wrote it all down.
好吧，希望能收到你的回信。好吧。是的，凯利说，你刚才是在语音信箱里约女孩出去吗？他说，是的。迈克尔在这一集里的“谈话头”，他有一个我喜欢的巨大的“谈话头”，我把它全写下来了。
Here it is. Last week, I would have given a kidney to anyone in the office. I would have reached right into my stomach and pulled it out for them. But now, no, I don't have the relationship with these people that I thought I did. I hope they ask.
在这里。上周，我会把肾脏给办公室里的任何人。我会直接伸进我的胃里把它掏出来给他们。但现在，不，我和这些人没有我以为的那种关系。我希望他们问。
So they can hear me say, oh, no, I only give my organs to my real friends. Go get yourself a monkey kidney. Oh my God. He's so mad. He's so mad, he's so hurt. He feels so betrayed. He really would have given them one of his organs.
这样他们就能听到我说，哦，不，我只把我的器官给我的真正朋友。你自己去弄个猴子肾吧。哦，天哪。他太生气了。他太生气了，他太受伤了。他觉得自己被背叛了。他真的会给他们一个他的器官。
You know he would have. Yeah, he would have. Now he's only gonna give you a monkey kidney. Poor Michael. Poor Michael. And then at 18 minutes 20 seconds, guess who calls? Todd Packer. Todd Packer, did you get that package I left for you? He's like, what package? Did I get package? Anybody see a package? Roy's like, do you mean the thing? The thing in your office? And Michael's delighted. Oh, what a funny prank.
你知道他会的。是的，他会的。现在他只会给你一个猴子肾。可怜的迈克尔。可怜的迈克尔。然后在18分20秒，猜猜谁打了电话？托德·帕克。托德·帕克，你收到我留给你的包裹了吗？他说，什么包裹？我收到包裹了吗？有人看到包裹了吗？罗伊说，你是说那个东西吗？你办公室里的那个东西？迈克尔很高兴。哦，多么有趣的恶作剧。
Oh, someone loves me. They want to do jokes. They want to poop on my floor. So funny. When Packer does it, it's a hilarious funny prank. No, when Packer does it, he says at 19 minutes, 13 seconds, it was done out of love. Just like I thought, which is not what he thought.
哦，有人爱我。他们想开玩笑。他们想在我的地板上拉屎。太有趣了。当帕克做的时候，这是一个搞笑的恶作剧。不，当帕克做的时候，他在19分13秒说，这是出于爱。就像我想的那样，这并不是他想的那样。
Oh. It's not what he thought. But I do think he's so relieved that it was no one in the office. Well, everything is right again, right? His universe makes sense again. This is my family. They wouldn't do that.
哦。这不是他想的那样。但我确实认为他很欣慰那不是办公室里的任何人。嗯，一切又恢复正常了，对吧？他的宇宙又说得通了。这是我的家人。他们不会那样做。
It's just crazy Todd Packer. Everything's okay. Well, then can we talk about the sweetest of sweet moments? Yes, I did write in my journal. I said, guys, I don't want to give anything away, but this has one of the sweetest endings of an episode yet. So this whole episode, we've given you no indication that Pam is clocking Jim in any way.
那只是疯狂的托德·帕克。一切都好。嗯，那我们能谈谈最甜蜜的时刻吗？是的，我确实在我的日记里写了。我说，伙计们，我不想剧透任何东西，但这有迄今为止最甜蜜的剧集结尾之一。所以这一整集，我们没有给你任何帕姆以任何方式关注吉姆的迹象。
In any way. But Jim walks to his desk, he sees the little message light flashing and he plays his messages and Pam has left him seven voicemails all about her day. And clearly she's missing him and missing interacting with him. Yeah. And you see him kind of walk to his car as these messages play. And his face. Oh, he's so happy.
以任何方式。但吉姆走到他的办公桌前，他看到小消息灯在闪烁，他播放了他的消息，帕姆给他留了七条关于她一天的语音留言。显然她很想念他，想念和他互动。是的。当你看到这些消息播放时，你看到他有点走到他的车前。他的脸。哦，他太高兴了。
Yeah. And everything is right in his world again. And kind of everything is right in our world again, And kind of everything is right in our world again too, because I think as an audience member, it's funny, I forgot about the voicemail messages when I was watching this. Yeah. And I was frustrated with Pam. I was like, what is wrong with you?
是的。他世界里的一切又恢复正常了。而且我们世界里的一切也恢复正常了，因为我想作为观众，很有趣，我在看这一集时忘记了语音留言。是的。我对帕姆感到沮丧。我当时想，你到底怎么了？
This is your friend, why are you being so coy? I skied a little and then like, say hi to the guy. I wasn't upset with Pam because I feel like she's, this is so complicated for her. I mean, I'm sure there's hills and valleys of her wanting to invest in Roy and what they've built together and see it through. And then there's all these overwhelming feelings of like,
这是你的朋友，你为什么要这么害羞？我滑了一点雪，然后就像，跟那个人打个招呼。我并没有对帕姆感到沮丧，因为我觉得她，这对她来说太复杂了。我是说，我相信她想投资罗伊和他们一起建立的东西并坚持到底，这中间有起起伏伏。然后还有所有这些压倒性的感觉，比如，
but I don't think he's the right person, but we've been together so long. Like it's, and then when she sees Jim, she's, it's like holding up a mirror to herself. I think it's complicated. But you're telling me she didn't miss him on the vacation. Yes, but admitting to missing him is admitting to this emotional affair and she's not there yet.
但我认为他不是对的人，但我们在一起太久了。就像是，然后当她看到吉姆时，她，这就像照镜子。我认为这很复杂。但你是说她在假期里没想他吗？是的，但承认想他就是承认这段情感外遇，她还没到那一步。
She's not there yet, but these messages meant the world to me as a viewer when I was watching it. Yes. I was like, yes, thank you. Thank you. And also guys, once again, I feel like Michael and Jim had a parallel storyline where they sort of lose the thing they love, which is, for Michael,
她还没到那一步，但作为观众，我在看的时候，这些信息对我来说意义重大。是的。我当时想，太好了，谢谢。谢谢。还有，伙计们，再说一次，我觉得迈克尔和吉姆有一条平行的故事线，他们都失去了自己热爱的东西，对迈克尔来说，
the acceptance of the office is friends. For Jim, it's Pam. But then in the end, it's all OK. It's going to be OK. Yeah. Aw. Aw. That's the carpet, guys.
是办公室作为朋友的接纳。对吉姆来说，是帕姆。但最后，一切都好。一切都会好起来的。是的。噢。噢。那是地毯，伙计们。
That's the carpet, everybody. I have a question. I want to throw it out there. Angela, do we need to start a second podcast where I re-watch Game of Thrones and we discuss it? With me? Yeah, with you. Yes.
那是地毯，各位。我有个问题。我想提出来。安吉拉，我们需要开启第二个播客吗？我重看《权力的游戏》，然后我们讨论它？和我一起？是的，和你一起。好的。
Office ladies do Game of Thrones. Oh my gosh. I would love that so much. I mean, I- Does anyone want to hear that? Does anyone want to hear me listen to Game of Thrones? Although, there might be some- Listen to me watch Game of Thrones?
《办公室女士》聊《权力的游戏》。天哪。我太喜欢这个主意了。我是说，我——有人想听吗？有人想听我聊《权力的游戏》吗？虽然，可能会有一些——听我聊我看《权力的游戏》？
Die Hard Game of Thrones fans will be like, no, you guys are gonna, you're gonna ruin it. All right. Next week we're gonna do Boys and Girls, which is a very exciting episode for Angela and I. We'll tell you all about how we had a hand in creating this episode. Yes. See you next week.
《权力的游戏》的铁杆粉丝会说，不，你们会毁了它的。好了。下周我们将讨论《男孩和女孩》，这对安吉拉和我来说是非常激动人心的一集。我们会告诉你们我们是如何参与创作这一集的。是的。下周见。
See you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Breton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布莱顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。